you know you're you're alternately kind
of blamed for all of the the wrongs of
silicon valley and
and kind of uh
giving credit for some of the birth of
these ideas and especially with the the
well which is a story that i think you
get to and you were part of and i think
i'd love for you to tell a little bit
about what you thought of the well as it
started and
and i'd love to hear what stewart got
out of that the wellesley the ark of the
well is an interesting story and
stewart's inner you know his creation of
the well and his exit from the well was
interesting to me as well but you know i
was one of these technology writers at
that point when the well started i was
just making the the transition
from bite magazine which is very
technical to the san francisco examiner
thank you will
and
you know
stewart's brilliant marketing move in
starting the well was that he gave free
accounts to people like me and steven
levy and a bunch of other technology
rights and to hackers and hackers that's
right uh it created this community but
it also basically gave the well an
out-of-scale reputation i don't think
there were never more than fourteen
thousand members of the well i would be
surprised yeah if i had to situate you
know there was a digital culture that
emerged but the well was a pretty small
part of it it wasn't first i mean there
was
i'm sorry the well uh is still uh but
you know there was um there there was
compuserve there was a source there was
prodigy and most importantly i think if
you wanted to situate a digital culture
there was usenet all of the unix
all the unix
data centers around the country were
connected and there was a very kind of
libertarian spirit a hacker spirit in
those and that basically was happening
at the same time it was phytonet was
going on all of this stuff was happening
and the well was a big big part of it
but it wasn't
um and you know the other thing that i
took away i called that chapter
anonymity um because stewart had seen
some of the things that we're now
recognizing now as problems in this
cyberspace metaphors what do you want to
call it and he tried to design the well
to to deal with them and
i think ultimately six years later you
decided you hadn't solved that problem
and you walked away from it
what i'd seen is that um
i've learned about the stuff that we did
on the well from a
system called eyes
uh e-i-e-s
i guess
and um
i was on a system with a limited
conversation of about 20 30 people
corporate people intellectuals
computer people
and um
we would meet twice a year and then just
sort of go through discussing various
things and then in a sense i was on the
faculty of this group
and
one of the discussion points that came
up is
anonymity is important because some
people need to be able to get a message
out without
coming back to really bite them uh
because it's an important truth and and
uh you know power will will find them
and destroy them
so uh let's have a little anonymous uh
sub conversation within these various
conversations that were having on eyes
and it was set up
and within two days it had gone
completely sociopathic
and what happens is when you have
anonymity people can pretend to be other
people
and uh as this other person then do
something really uh
sort of insighty jokey and cruel
and then that gets the other people who
are also now realizing they're anonymous
to be equally cruel back
and uh it spirals into real viciousness
really fast
and so that was why i wanted to be sure
that that kind of anonymity was not
going to be available on the well but we
did allow people to change their names
and it wound up being easy for them to
get separate accounts and they'd be
kicked off the well and they'd come back
and somebody else and
uh we did not control it
and facebook originally it was your
facebook identity that was going to be
your digital identity in the world and
then that got lost for them
and
you see the downstream so i think
still that
you own your own words you're
responsible for your own words
and
it's not only that you're responsible
for your own words on the line it's
actually a loyal you not a bot
not somebody else pretending to be you
it's actually you and it's the true
names thing that vernafinger wrote about
i think we're going to need to have that
or at least a channel where that is
always really a lot reliable yeah
yeah and it's pretty much a microcosm of
exactly what we're living through now at
a macro scale
and so i
i think it's interesting how early that
lesson was learned yet not really
not actually learned yeah
the the cyberpunk science fiction
writers laid this all out for us in the
1980s what did they get about what they
were writing yeah i think people used it
as a road map instead of a warning i
blame myself i mean i you know i fell
for john barlow's john perry barlow's
utopianism as much as anybody else did
you know this was going to be this
socratian abode that was going to be
separate from the real world well there
was a lot of people standing behind john
kind of rolling our eyes
he would spin that out
but i think and that's worth touching on
too i mean there's the time i mean even
the time as long i was getting started
in the mid 90s where you know there was
the techno optimism was a was very much
part of of the
your scene and the long now founding um
and then as as that optimism has has
certainly faded in some cases turned to
absolute terror
how do you how do you feel in your kind
of birth of this movement and then where
it's gone and
and and that
the
the pendulum of attention that goes from
everything is great about an actually
mixed bag
to everything is terrible about an
actually mixed bag
um
is
i don't know i guess one of the ways
that people catch on
learn that it actually is a mixed bag
because you have to oscillate
um but it's a mixed bag from
from the go
and it's a mixed bag every step of the
way
uh you could say oh gosh facebook is so
evil because it's that any other thing
facebook is an absolute blessing for
most people most of the time
and that reality hasn't changed
you know there have some issues that are
still being sorted out and there are
quite consequential issues affect
presidential elections and things like
that
but they do get sorted out and i suppose
the
optimism is that you bear down on the
problems
you don't solve them right away the
really tough problems do not get solved
right away climate is in that category
and and online behavior i think is in
that category there's lots of paradoxes
built into it you've got to sort your
way through them
um
gregory bateson and said he worked with
schizophrenics a lot he said that
you you'll see people who are as
schizophrenic as they ever were but they
sort of manage in the world
he said that's like learning to ride a
crazy horse
uh
the problem with the horse is you
want it to go left and instead it
goes right and dumps you off and runs
away
but
you can figure out the situation of the
crazy crazy horse and people have these
neuroses
sometimes we talk therapy sometimes with
drugs sometimes just with life figure
out how to manage the damn thing
and ride the crazy horse and i think we
do that at the
social and civilizational and cultural
level as well
well i think this is the thing that you
point out in the book we have a few
questions along these lines as well
is that um kind of stewart also
knew when to leave
in some way or maybe
maybe
knowing is the right is the wrong term
but
he always leave early
yeah there's
but there was this this restlessness and
and even sometimes you know these
failures like the education thing that
that then and somehow kind of launched
into the next thing so yeah what did you
learn in like watching those cycles well
i mean i think stewart explained it to
me as he he had a relatively short
attention so you have a relatively short
attention span you would tend to get
bored and moved on move on that was
actually something that worked your
advantage
yeah and you know the five year thing
that we talked about it's sort of a
project that is going somewhere takes
about five years to
mature
and
if you have a sort of a five-year
attention span which i guess i did
um
one point i wrote when when you can do
the thing you're doing in your sleep
wake up
go somewhere else and and
things would get to that point where you
sort of can see what's coming and oya is
coming around again
um
and if invention is
what turns you on
uh
you're not getting it anymore from that
particular
domain and so you have to go somewhere
else yeah
and and there's
back when we had gears and gear shifts
uh
you had to go through neutral between
gears
that's kind of true and so there's a
period
um bob before
uh would say that you know you're
somebody and then
you're nobody
and that you know when you call that
chapter anonymity i thought you were
referring to sort of a period when i was
nobody
and uh
it's important i think
that
and fuller really pointed this out
if you get addicted to being somebody
you will become a character of yourself
because you'll be you know picking up on
what people think you're famous for
um
and in order to
escape from that you have to give up on
being somebody
and be nobody a while but nobody is a
fantastic place to be it's like the art
student who's just out of school and
doesn't have a job
they're open to the world and that's
maybe the
hungry state foolish thing is is to be
relish being a nobody